when we say we don't have faith in our
institutions what the heck are we
talking about like I got on a plane to
come here
if you think about the devil in Comet it
crashed all the time
planes don't crash anymore they used to
those are institutions that are keeping
the same people who lose your luggage
and who delay and overbook you make sure
that your plane doesn't crash and so
you're having a weird Association I
can't trust the Airlines and I totally
trust the airline you trust the airline
to screw up your flight to overcharge
you to overbook you to do all this stuff
and you trust them absolutely with your
family and your life
to take off on a death trap filled with
jet fuel from one situation not knowing
the weather somewhere else
and land
we do trust our institutions and we
don't and we do and we don't and it's
making us crazy well that's the worst
thing right if we just didn't trust them
that would be a lot easier it's the it's
this ambiguity it's Schrodinger's
yes
and and this is what's making us mad the
cheap thing to say is I can't trust the
institutions that's right the weirdest
thing to say is I don't understand why
they're so good and so bad
simultaneously that's right why are they
so good and so bad simultaneously
um I think because
there's a centralized reason why they
they started screwing up which is this
theory of embedded growth obligations
what's that telling we have no idea what
that is
assume that from 1945 where World War II
seals in an order from a really decisive
Victory up until
1968-73. it's not that WTF happened in
71 as the Bitcoin it's sort of 68.73.
that period of broad
distributed
technologically LED Dependable high
levels of growth deranged us
we thought that was our future
and we built a society in a world that
required that level of growth
and sometimes you have an organism that
has multiple life cycles
a guy named Mark Tash and he wrote a
book called the genetic switch about the
fact that uh
T4 bacteriophage Lambda phage Lambda has
two different lives that can lead and I
think in part the West has two different
lives it can lead it can lead a high
growth life uh life cycle or it can lead
a low growth life cycle when we say we
don't recognize ourselves and are we the
same people who won World War II or
something like that
we don't recognize that that is one of
our potential life cycles nobody had
ever seen the low growth Western
life cycle and it's terrifying it's it's
us eating each other
I must grow my slice of the pie just the
way my great grandfathers grew their
slice of the pie and the only way I can
do that if the pie isn't growing fast
enough is to eye your slice
so I'm looking at your slice and
suddenly we each appear to each other
not as a source of inspiration but as a
source of protein and nourishment
and that's but that's that's fear-based
response isn't it Eric well it's a
realistic response in other words if I'm
doing something that's growth based and
if I suffused all of these institutions
with certain growth obligations the
portion of that institution like its
pension fund that had to grow at a level
that it cannot grow at become
psychopathic
right is that why we print endless money
that we don't have and borrow from our
grandchildren
yes
that in essence what happened was north
of Bretton Woods collapsing and the
removal of the gold standard it was the
loss of technological change in fuel
that came easily in the 20th century so
there are all sorts of disasters in the
20th century but there are all sorts of
Marvels
and when those started to dry up which
essentially came from something I've
called umvelt hacking that you could see
more and more with scientific
instrumentation so you could look into
the cell at some point you had to guess
it with the three-dimensional structure
of DNA was at some point you could
basically look at
right so we started to get into a place
where we couldn't sustain the science
the science couldn't detain sustain the
technology the technology couldn't
sustain the markets and everything had
been built with an obligation
so the whole point of this theory of
egos or embedded growth obligations is
how do we have a theory why all
institutions would sort of get into
trouble at once
and it's the common thing is growth that
can't be met
right so that's that's why everything
went funny now that's not to say that
we're not analytic if we didn't want to
lie to keep this game going
we could fix a lot of things so things
that do get fixed are things like uh
airplane checklists to make sure that we
don't take off with something broken the
checklist is also operative in a
hospital so you don't amputate the wrong
leg so the the explosion in iatrogenics
which is that harms done by harm done by
physicians to their own patients and the
epidemic of crashes that ended both in
part result from a common uh
understanding in management that a
checklist is a life-saving thing
we could do that with Integrity to
the growth based Parts the pension I
could say to you actually you know these
commitments we made to your pension
can't be met
um here's what's realistic and here's
what's safe what do you guys how do you
guys feel about two percent or you know
or 1.5 percent growth and you say well
can I retire not really very well
you might paid my whole life into
helping other people yeah your part
you're you're the loser of the pyramid
scheme how do you feel
well you don't feel good that's the part
I have to start lying about right
I've been thinking about this a lot man
because
um
that's really
every every time I I haven't been able
to work out up until this conversation
why every time there's a crisis
no one says we we have a limited amount
of money no no one ever says that uh
it's like in this country the com the
NHS is always underfunded every you know
if if the electricity prices or gas
prices go up the government has to
support people right and I know who
could disagree with that well and tell
me something how many of these people
know the word senior age
none do you no no
senior age is a tax
on the holders of money
that they experience when you print more
of it
right so in essence
when the money supply goes up and you
say you know we really need
um to do something about uh monetary
policy in order to alleviate the
pressure
you're really saying we need to tax the
holders of money
by uh printing more of it so you're
raising money through senior age and
then you have like all of these other
things they're really bizarrely
explained like a stock market crash
stocks fell today in a precipitous
decline over the last three trading
hours that's not what happened at all
the right way of saying it is the dollar
surged against equities
or the pounds surged against the footsie
you know and and what is it you've got
this amazing and beautiful numerator
which is an index fund let's say
500 stocks for the s p but what's your
denominator oh it's the dollar it's one
instrument and that one instrument is
further disguised by being called the
numerator it's the measuring step
so now you're playing games with a
rubberized measuring stick and when the
measuring stick moves that's what caused
all the equities to apparently fall it's
it's not the price of equities it's an
exchange rate with another instrument
and the other instrument surged
so what we do is we keep you in a
Perpetual state of stupidity
so and the reason that they do that is
because if they're honest
that will precipitate a loss of
confidence and if there's a loss of
confidence then the whole thing
collapses like the cut house of cards
that it is well correct and you don't
want a complete loss of confidence you
want theater you want you want
belief
but you want a higher level adult level
you want an adult level of fiction
these fictions are dangerous
unsustainable
you know there's a French philosopher
Jamie charteris told me this and it
changed my life he said a nation is
defined to be a group of people who have
agreed to forget something in common
and you have to understand the purpose
of of nonsense of theater of BS of
aspiration
the U.S had some of the best of this
stuff
all men being created equal when you
held slaves
it wasn't true it was honored only
initially in the breach
but it was open-ended and it gave the
opportunity when you had the opportunity
to get rid of your slavery to promote
something to all men truly being equal
oh